pour ces 1 boucle dans boris becker
mazen viège jeter roulera bien une
pelleteuse à les joindre
et puis
à
et hélas il faut lui en enlever molle tu
me rappelles total
y avoir des différences ne passe pas par
le bois un conseil il ya de la triche
aux jeunes c'est très bien en chaîne
j'embrasse catherine qu'est ce que c'est
seront réunis les liens riffing de dire
on fait plaisir
mon accent brésilien bonsu coach albert
pendant je me fais corrigé hier je
reviens c'est vrai que ces dix dernières
années tu t'es beaucoup fruité avec les
miss si celle ci de là deux sens laure
belleville 96 patricia spécial spehar
97-98 thalmann atama 19 galanter de
commencer
sagna 2001 elodie 2002 ma belle sylvie
2003 corinne coman 2004 que quelqu'un
dise elle est en ce moment à la niche et
deux nuls en langues cindy fabre
laquelle laquelle tu préfères alain toi
merci valérie ma chérie valérie encore
william est bien sonia rolland oui quand
on pense que le parcours
l'été arrive et me c'est pour ça qu'elle
est partie du rwanda caféier de toutes
les rondelles
justement c'est ce que veut dire
politique ça veut dire qu'on peut
arriver du rwanda et au caire en france
voilà